I'm here with Suzanne Frye director of
security trust and privacy at Google
cloud she's responsible for ensuring we
gain our customers trust for the
extensive transparency visibility and
controls Suzanne thanks for taking the
time to be with us today
thank you so why should businesses trust
Google cloud
what kind of commitments do we make that
protects them Google was born in the
cloud and we've been cloud native since
day one now what does that mean that
means that we've thought about security
and privacy and how we build an
architect our data centers servers
networks devices and applications it's
allowed us sort of to move at the speed
of the world since day one and with
respect to security and privacy threats
and I think that's super important for
folks to understand we have optimized
for the cloud and how does that get
reflected in the commitments we make
absolutely so we put our money where our
mouth is we put all of our commitments
to security and privacy in contract
these are binding documents as you know
so that customers can feel comfortable
knowing that we are committed to their
security and privacy now the customers
still know us very much as a consumer
company strong brand very strong
consumer presence and enterprise
customers sometimes have a few questions
around that can you give me some clarity
on the differences and what exactly
happens to enterprise data for example
so going back to the cloud native
approach that we've taken we've built a
tremendous business in fact there's
seven businesses at Google with over a
billion consumer users apiece and just
look at that track record stand alone we
bring all of the power of that track
record to our enterprise customers and
even more we talked about contracts but
we also you know commit to not scanning
your data for advertising we commit that
you can take your data with you we
commit that you have right to understand
where your data is being
and your IP will belong to you and
earlier when I was talking with Dan and
Rene we talked about transparency
because cloud relationships aren't like
standard packaged enterprise software
relationships we don't sell and leave we
have to kind of earn it and win it on
this rolling basis and also keep people
informed around new features what's
coming up in the product side and they
were saying that the change management
and the training involved makes
transparency very important and
communications important from Google's
perspective why is transparency
important well you put yourself in the
shoes of any CIO or C so who's making a
decision to move from on-premise to the
cloud or even another cloud provider to
ours and you really have to understand
you know how am I going to know I am
safe and secure you know we believe we
are in trust through transparency
knowing what's happening to your data at
any given time super critical for
earning that trust security is a sense
that you control your environment right
and a transparency means you can see and
control as much as possible just kind of
the yeah the idea behind that I guess so
finally what are three things you'd like
viewers to take from this session well
we've touched on all three in some
capacity for example pillar number one
is compliance we're committed to our
customers compliance examples being
things like gdpr and FedRAMP we have to
be ahead of the curve with respect to
global compliance regimes and we
recognize you know our compliance as our
customers compliance to we're committed
to transparency trust through
transparency and enabling customers to
understand what we're doing with their
data and thirdly we're committed to
control you are in control of your data
and not only with Portability and things
like that but also the ability to turn
off services or control the security of
your devices or understand you know
which executives in your organization
should have a security key
and implement and enforce that as scale
so those are the three things compliance
transparency and control Suzanne thank
you for joining us thank you